[Music]
it's not cooked all the way
hey everyone it's Jerry and if you know
me I love challenging Myself by taking
ingredients using them in unconventional
ways to make new dishes today I have a
special guest who's going to challenge
me to use one mystery ingredient in
three different dishes let's see what it
is hi Jerry how are you my name is H Wu
I am a food content creator based in Los
Angeles and I am here to present Jerry a
mystery ingredient all right I'm a
little nervous the big plates with a big
plate lid thingy what are these called
three two one
oh gosh a coconut I would love you can
make me three different meals with this
one secret ingredient I'm up for the
challenge I trust you okay you can do
this your tasking me with making three
dishes I feel like you can open the
cookies okay oh wow the way my mom
showed me is she would take the back of
the cleaver like this and hold the
coconut and then there's like these eyes
of the coconut and she would kind of
hack at it I mean there's only one way
to find out
there's juice coming out okay one more
give it one more hack
stop
that's good I wish you best of luck on
making these three meals I'm gonna go
kicking on the couch and just wait
you're not yeah I guess it's just me I
feel like age who is a force to be
reckoned with so I'm going to be making
him coconut cinnamon rolls with coconut
filling and a coconut cream cheese
frosting I know it's a mouthful but it's
going to be amazing so to kick things
off I am going to first Bloom the yeast
I'm gonna add some sugar to the Bowl
some melted coconut oil and we have our
warm coconut milk and last but not least
our yeast so I'm just going to sprinkle
this over the top and give it a nice
little whisk all right this is nicely
whisked I'm gonna set this to the side
and let it do its thing for about 10
minutes our yeast has bloomed now I'm
going to add the flour to the wet
ingredients I haven't made cinnamon
rolls like this before so I'm super
excited to see how this turns out some
arm strengthen this I'm like I'm going
to just cover this with my towel here
let it sit to the side for an hour until
it's doubled in size okay now we're
going to move on to our filling we're
gonna kick things off by adding these
dry roasted hazelnuts to our the
processor this feels perfect coconut
flakes I'm gonna break up this brown
sugar and add that too add some coconut
flour and now a pinch of salt and I'm
going to give this a nice mix I'm going
to add some softened butter another
round of mixing last round of mixing I'm
going to add one egg and a little
coconut extract one last mix beautiful
so the texture is perfect I'm going to
transfer it to a bowl and then
refrigerate it for an hour so our dough
has doubled in size and now I'm going to
start by adding the flour baking powder
and last but not least salt and now I'm
going to give this a nice stir kind of
fold it so this looks perfect I'm now
going to turn this onto my clean work
surface what I forgot to do was flour my
Surface prior to doing that so we're
going to do that now and it's going to
get a little messy but that's why this
is fun so just go with it I've needed my
dough it looks beautiful next step is to
roll out our dough and I wanted about a
half inch thick we have our perfect
rectangle here then I'm going to come in
with my bench scraper and just kind of
make sure the edges are nice and even
I'm going to add this beautiful coconut
hazelnut filling I'm going to start
rolling it I want to be very gentle with
this part so what I do is kind of just
lift like that and some may say this is
a little like exaggerated but sometimes
I'll have my forearm on it as I'm
rolling it to keep it consistent almost
done a labor of love but sweetly broke
up my little trick for getting those
perfectly cut pieces is by using this
handy dandy floss and when you use this
be sure to use floss that's not flavored
I'm going to start by trimming the edges
and you just bring it over like this and
pull together and look at that what I'm
going to do is bring this floss all the
way to the middle and then do that again
the reason why I'm separating these two
is because I'm going to be baking these
in two separate baking dishes so we're
going to start adding these in
containers here we go they're in their
baking dish we're going to put this to
the side and allow it to prove okay
these lovelies are ready for baking
let's go ahead and put these in the oven
look at these golden brown Beauties I am
going to set these to the side to cool
for just a little bit and then start
working on the coconut cream cheese
frosting so I'm going to start by adding
this room temperature cream cheese to a
bowl and mixing it until it's light and
fluffy and then next I'm going to add
this room temperature butter and just
repeat that same thing beautiful I'm
going to add my powdered sugar and I'm
going to sift this first the reason why
I sift it is to just break up any clumps
I'm going to use this hand mixer and
just mix all the ingredients next I'm
going to add my coconut milk and lastly
I'm going to add coconut extract last
mix take a look at this it is beautiful
the texture is nice and smooth we have
no lumps here it just smells like a
coconut dream okay my cinnamon rolls
have been cooling for about 10 minutes
and I think now is about a good time to
spread the coconut cream cheese frosting
on top I brought it I feel like I
brought it with this one and this is
just breakfast
it's not cooked all the way
okay I just sampled that little piece
right there and although it looked
cooked on top it wasn't cooked through
so I'm really glad we have that second
batch because I think we're gonna
default to that one because I can't give
this day to you all right round two
we're gonna try this again I feel a lot
more confident that these are cooked
through so I'm going to top them with
our coconut cream cheese frosting and
then I'm going to plate one for H Wu and
perfect this plate was made for the
cinnamon roll all right now on to lunch
I'm going to be making H Wu kinilau
which is also referred to as Filipino
Ceviche so what makes this dish super
unique is the use of coconut vinegar and
I'm part Filipino and coconut milk is
really prevalent in a lot of our cooking
so this is a big reason why I kind of
lean towards this I have here sushi
grade salmon that's been perfectly cubed
thanks to the amazing culinary team I'm
going to add some lime juice and lastly
coconut vinegar and what this step does
just kind of eliminate that fishy odor
and really just refreshes the salmon and
then I'm going to strain the mixture
okay it looks like it's still draining
what I'm going to do is cover this with
a towel leave it in the fridge and then
work on the rest ingredients for the
quinoa now I'm going to slice these
onions and these are just going to be
topped onto the kinilo I'm going to
transfer these sliced onions to an ice
bath and what this does is it eliminates
that sulfur kind of astringent strong
bite that you get from onions now we're
moving on to the dressing which should
be a little tart a little sweet but big
on Citrus flavor starting with coconut
vinegar lime juice which is an Asian
citrus coconut milk kosher salt and
lastly sugar I'm going to give this a
nice whisk just to get everything nicely
mixed so now we're going to make the
chips for the kinilau we could have went
with like a taro chip but I wanted
something that was a little bit heartier
a nice strong vessel we ended up with a
plantain I'm going to start by cutting
both ends off then I'm going to cut it
down the middle right here give it a
nice peel what am I doing why didn't I
just do this my mom would be looking at
me in it right now like what are you
doing child next I'm going to use my
favorite Gadget of all time and slice
them into really thin strips so I've
sliced the plantain perfectly thin and
now it's time to fry get that nice
Sizzle these are perfect they're ready
to be pulled out I'm going to drain the
excess oil off first then place it on my
wire rack so while these are still hot
I'm going to top them with a little bit
of salt and I'm going to repeat till I'm
done all right y'all it's assembly time
starting with the dressing I'm going to
add that to the salmon then I'm going to
add mango coconut Thai chili for a
little kick Ginger I am a ginger girl so
I'm gonna add a lot I hope H Food likes
Ginger too green onion and our perfectly
crisp red onion and give it a mix and
what's really nice is right before Age
We taste it this is all going to sit
together so all the seasonings and
flavorings have time to marry the way I
want to do this is I kind of want to
have it all in the center and then have
the juice surrounding it kind of like a
little moat and then I am going going to
finish it off with some cucumber slices
just to make it a little fancy a little
kind of pretty there and last but not
least our plantain chips and there you
go this is like the perfect dish for
lunch let's move on to dinner so for
dinner I'm going to be making ravioli
with coconut ricotta swimming in a
coconut cream sauce and topped with
coconut bacon all served with a coconut
sugar cured egg yolk that sounds like a
mouthful because it is but it's going to
be the best thing he's ever had I feel
like I'm gonna kick things off by making
the coconut sugar cured egg yolk so to a
bowl I'm going to add coconut sugar
followed by kosher salt I just want to
give it a good whisk I'm going to add
half of this mixture into this bowl
right here and I'm going to reserve the
other half and I'll show you why in this
first Bowl right here I'm going to make
two Wells for the two egg yolks that I'm
going to cure then I have two eggs I'm
going to separate the yolks I'm going to
drop it into the first well right here
carefully and repeat with the second one
into the second well I'm going to take
the remaining half of the coconut sugar
and kosher salt mix moisture and just
pour it right on top so what you would
do for these is let these cure for 48
hours but with the help of our amazing
culinary team they've done that step for
me we have these beautiful cured egg
yolks as you can see here once I do a
little rinse that the yolks have deepen
in color that is beautiful for this next
step we're going to make the coconut
ricotta so we're going to add coconut
milk coconut cream next we have apple
cider vinegar a little bit of garlic
powder lemon juice lemon zest salt onion
powder and black pepper this step is
going to act as our binder this is the
agar agar and the reason we're adding
this is because this is not a
traditional cheese we're using coconut
milk so it doesn't have that typical
protein that you would find in like
cow's milk I'm going to transfer this
mixture to a bowl so the next step here
is to refrigerate for two days but the
culinary team that we have has already
done this for us so we're just going to
swap this out and voila coconut ricotta
the last step for this coconut ricotta
is to add lemon zest parsley and chives
and give this a nice little fold this
legit looks like whipped ricotta to me
this is beautiful so I'm going to
transfer this to a Piping Bag keep it
fridge until it's ready for use now I'm
making the ravioli dough I'm going to
start by separating eight eggs from its
yolks and then adding one whole egg to
this bowl I'm just gonna whisk it up to
a standing mixer I'm going to add flour
kosher salt the eggs I'm going to mix
this until it forms into a ball our
dough has come together and now I'm
going to knead it for about seven
minutes until it comes together I'm now
going to wrap this up and refrigerate
for two hours to allow it to rest I am
going to be making coconut bacon and
since I'm not sure of the texture I'm
trying to achieve I'm going to be using
both coconut flakes and coconut shreds
I'm going to add all of these
ingredients to a bowl smoked paprika
black pepper kosher salt olive oil soy
sauce maple syrup Liquid Smoke and brown
sugar specifically with the addition of
the smell smoked paprika and the liquid
smoke that's going to give us that taste
that we're looking for when we have
bacon I'm just going to split this
mixture up time to cook our coconut
bacon and I'm going to give each of
these mixtures its own baking sheet
because I'm not sure how long it's going
to take to cook I'm going to put both of
these in the oven at 350 degrees for
about 10 minutes and rotate them halfway
through next up we have our sauce it's
going to be a beautiful brown butter
Sage coconut cream sauce I'm going to
start by adding the butter as it Browns
I'll start to see little bits and start
smelling a Nutty Aroma I'm now going to
add the sage to it give it a little stir
and just kind of cook that up for about
a minute or until the sage is aromatic
I'm going to add the coconut cream nice
and creamy and buttery I'm going to turn
this off and then add lemon zest parsley
chives just give that a good stir our
coconut cream sauces just about finished
I'm just going to add a pinch of salt
and that's it now it's time to make our
ravioli I'm going to divide my my dough
up into four pieces then I'm going to
make sure that both sides of the dough
are heavily floured because I'm then
going to pass it through my pasta maker
let's start with the first pass I'm
going to keep doing this until I get to
step five that is so fun okay I'm Legit
excited right now I'm like oh my gosh I
am so excited so starting off I'm going
to cut this into two big squares then
I'm going to take one side of the
smaller Circle and just do a light
indentation into the dough next I'm
going to pipe it within the circle so
I'm going to leave just a little bit of
room so I don't go out of the bounds of
the circle and just fill in this part
I'm going to take the second sheet and
put it right on top all right we have
the filling right in the center so now
I'm going to cut the ravioli with a
bigger Circle and push completely down
and last but not least just go ahead and
take the smaller Circle and shape it a
little little bit but be very careful
not to poke through and you have ravioli
I'm going to assemble the recipes and
then cook our ravioli the water is
boiling so I'm going to add the first
one works so hard to get to this point
so I can't wait to see how this one
turns out and okay wow wow that was not
what I wanted it looks like it kind of
oozed out from the side so it wasn't
completely sealed that was a fail that
was an ultimate fail let's try that
again we're looking good so far wow this
is ready to be taken out I'm going to
carefully lift it from the pot gorgeous
look at that the moment you've all been
waiting for I have my ravioli plated now
I'm going to spoon some sauce over it
beautiful if you remember we have our
coconut bacon I'm gonna go with the
flakes and last but not least I'm going
to take my cured egg yolks and just
grate it and that's going to act as like
my palm that's ready for you H2O you've
stuck around you've watched me make
three different dishes now it's time for
each try all of them I'm very excited to
see what you did I decided to do a
breakfast lunch and dinner here is your
first dish which is a coconut cinnamon
roll with coconut hazelnut filling and a
coconut cream cheese frosting cinnamon
rolls are like my favorite guilty
pleasure is this like your Kryptonite
this is straight up this looks fantastic
I'm just gonna take a fat bite right now
and commit you have to commit
fantastic really fantastic I actually
really like the texture of the coconut
coming through but it wasn't
overwhelmingly coconut either because I
could still taste the Integrity of a
cinnamon roll give it like a 9 out of
ten I don't know how the other two
dishes that's just round one that's
breakfast get ready for lunch meow and
which is like a Filipino version of
Ceviche I used a coconut dressing you
see some coconut meat in there as well
I'm excited I mean it looks beautiful
I want to say it's better than Ceviche
after taking a couple of bites do you
get that coconut Essence absolutely I
would honestly eat the whole thing which
is like we're not filming right now I
give you a 8.9 out of 10. you can be
honest like if something's a logistics
like just come through to come through
with the true rating no no okay that's
good I am most excited for dinner you
ready first off we have a coconut
ricotta ravioli it's bathing in a
beautiful coconut cream sauce beautiful
coconut bacon bits and then finish it
with a coconut sugar cured egg yolks it
looks gorgeous boom yeah money shot use
my bite that's beautiful
[Music]
I think this is my favorite it has like
saltiness richness got a little bit of
sweetness from the coconut this is
fantastic I gave it like a
9.2 come on 9.2 out of ten yeah you know
my job here's Dad I am quite impressed
with what you did with that young little
coconut that we massacred earlier you're
too good at this I feel like you need a
much harder ingredient next time well
I'm up for the challenge so let me know
in the comments what ingredient you want
me to use next see you next time
get that other eye there you go it's
okay it's just my eye why is it still
going that's not how I thought this
would go I'm kind of shocked why is it
still going
[Music]